سنوات مضت على ثبات وضع المكون الكردي في
تركيا لم يتغير بتغير قاده البلاد الا
نسبيا
معرضه وحكومه يتبارزون في النواحي
الاقتصاديه والدستوريه الا انهم تاريخيا
اتفقوا على منهج واحد تجاه الاكراد
الناخبون الاكراد في تركيا طاقوا ذرعا
بحالتهم كمواطنين من الدرجه الثانيه ومن
توصيفهم بالارهابيين كما يصافحون وبحلول
الانتخابات التركيه لهذا العام تتساءل عده
اطراف عن امكانيه تغيير في الشكل المعتاد
وعن اي تحول سترسمه نتيجه الانتخابات في
مستقبل المكون الكردي في حال فوز اردوغان
انا باعتقادي ان مرحله جديده من التصعيد
ضد الكرد سواء في تركيا او في الخارج
ستبدا خاصه ان اجنده اردوغان معروفه
وواضحه وهذه الاجنده تقوم على محاربه
التطلعات القوميه للكرد وبالرغم من ان
بقاء اردوغان في السلطه يتربص بهم ليتجه
اكبر الاحزاب السياسيه الكرديه وهو حزب
الشعوب الديمقراطي الى عباءه المعارضه
التركيه الا ان الاجابات التاريخيه لا
تبدي اي اختلاف جذري وواضح في السياسه
اتجاه الاكراد من قبل اي شكل حكم في تركيا
الا ان منع الحكومه الحاليه للاحزاب
الكرديه من طرح مرشحها مال بها الى خندق
المعارضه بقياده مرشحها كمالك الاشدار
التصريحات الرئيس اردوغان وكذلك منافسه
كمالك الجدار اوغلو اتجاه الاكراد هي
تصريحات انا باعتقادي انتخابيه بالدرجه
الاولى والهدف منها هو الحصول على اكبر
نسبه من اصوات الاكراد نظرا لان هذه
الاصوات ربما تكون حاسمه في تحديد هويه من
سيفوز في هذه الانتخابات مصلحه متبادله
بين الطرفين
13% من الناخبين في تركيا هم اكراد
تحتاجهم الطاوله السداسيه المتسمه بالطابع
قومي تركي لدعم موقفها بينما تحصيل الحقوق
الثقافيه والسياسيه للاكراد هو شرط دعم
حزب الشعوب لاي مرشح يقف في وجه اردوغان
ليبقى ذلك رهن المجهول حتى اشعار اخر في
حال فوز كالجدار اوغلو ان باعتقادي ان
تركيا ستدخل مرحله جديده من الحراك
الديمقراطي خاصه ان وثيقه المبادئ التي تم
اعلانها هذه الوثيقه لاحظت الكثير من
القضايا التي تتعلق بالحقوق المدنيه
الانتخابات في تركيا متغيره تاريخيا لكن
الثابته اتفاق جميع من حكم تركيا على موقف
واحد تجاه قضيه الاكراد
ومع هذا يبقى المكون الكردي يتطلع لتغيير
في كل مره تجري فيها الانتخابات عمر
العربيه
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات